[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHAN HERHUT: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Stephan.
I'm a software
engineer at Google,
where I work on compilers
and runtime systems.
And most recently,
I've been working
on R8, which is Google's
new shrinker for Android
applications.
Now, if you attended
yesterday's session
on new compilers
and Android Studio,
you already heard a fair
bit about what R8 is
and how you can use it.
And today, I don't want to talk
too much, actually, what R8 is.
I want to focus
more on keep rules.
So what are keep rules?
Keep rules is the
configuration language
that ProGuard uses to
specify the things you
need to keep in your
application while shrinking.
And when we built
R8, we decided we
wanted to use the same
language because we wanted
to be a drop-in
replacement for ProGuard,
the idea being that you could
just reuse your existing rules
and try R8 really easily.
Now, as you might imagine,
building something
that is compatible to
that degree required
us to quite deeply understand
what ProGuard keep rules
actually mean.
And today, I want to
use this opportunity
to share some of that
knowledge with you.
And I also want to take
you on a little journey
to understand what it really
takes, given an application,
to come up with effective
keep rules to shrink it
to its minimum.
But before we go there, let
me ask you all the questions.
So who of you has used ProGuard
before in some way or shape?
Wow.
That's a lot of people.
So who of you is
using ProGuard today
in the Released Production
app on the Play Store?
That's already a little less,
but you're a great crowd.
Thank you for doing that,
because our estimates show
that only about a quarter of
applications on the Play Store
actually use keep rules.
So there's a big
room for improvement.
And I want to talk a little bit
about why it actually matters
to shrink application size.
So, of course, for me,
it matters, because I
helped build a shrinker.
Right?
I'm interested that
somebody uses it.
But it should also
matter for you.
There has been a lot of talk
about next billion users,
entry-level Android devices,
and how we can make the user
experience better.
And what makes an entry-level
user Android device?
So one thing is, it's
really resource-limited.
So if you think
of these devices,
they typically have less
than 512 megabytes of RAM,
or they might only have like
four gigabytes of storage.
And quite often, people
that use these devices
are in areas where they have
very limited connectivity.
So for these users,
size actually
makes a daily difference.
Right?
When they decide of all
the apps they actually
want to use which ones
they can afford to install,
there might be a small subset.
And that's bad for them because
it's a bad user experience,
but it's also really bad for
you as application developers,
because it might be your app
that doesn't make the cut.
It might be your app that
they actually want to use,
but they can't use, because
they don't have the space.
Now, you might say, OK,
that's not really my audience.
Next billion users,
entry level, that's
not where I see my application.
But even if you target
really high-end devices,
the fundamental truth is that
smaller is always faster.
And that's quite
obvious, because, A,
they download faster,
because they are smaller.
There's less to transfer.
They also install a lot
faster, because there's
less code to compile,
and that what
takes the time at installing.
And lastly, and that's
what users see every day,
they also start up much
faster because there's
less code to load.
So whenever I talk
to people about this
and say, OK, you have to care,
you have to make them smaller,
an answer I get really,
really often is, yeah,
but hardware will fix this.
Right?
Devices are becoming faster.
There's more storage.
Connectivity is better.
That might be true, but
it's not a solution.
I have a graph for you.
So this shows the average
size of installed apps
on people's devices.
And as you can see, this
has been growing steadily.
Since the early
days of Android, we
started at about
a megabit per APK.
And by now, we are at a
whopping 32 megabytes,
on average, for
installed applications.
So clearly, hardware is
not going to fix this.
We have to do
something about it.
We have to make apps smaller.
So let's look at this.
Where does this
growth come from?
Why are apps so big?
And to get an idea, I thought
I'd bring you a little example.
So I built this app, which
I call Simple Weather,
and the stress
really is on simple.
Because all this
app does, it take
some statically
pre-defined weather data
and then renders it
as a dynamic graph.
Dynamic graph means
if you turn the app,
it will render in
a different size,
or if you install it
on a different device,
it will adapt to resolution.
So the graph is truly dynamic.
The data isn't.
And this is a really,
really simple app.
And there's are two
things that I found
surprising when
I built this app.
The positive thing was, it
took me all but 30 minutes.
I just went on the internet,
I looked for a graph library,
I typed in about
100 lines of code,
and there it was, my
little Simple Weather app.
But there was also
a negative surprise.
And that was the size.
I thought I built
something simple and small
because that makes it
small, but that's not true.
This app was two
megabytes of an APK.
Two megabytes just
for rendering a graph.
And even worse, when
I installed this,
it turns into a
four-megabyte blob of code
because it was uncompressed.
And again, you might
say, OK, four megabytes.
That's not really much.
Right?
New devices.
Lots of space.
Let me put that into
perspective for you.
If you look back into the
'60s, we flew to the moon
with 60k of code.
Right?
That's 1/60 of the
application size
I had for my Simple
Weather here.
And no matter how
you turn this, it's
strictly more complicated
to fly to the moon
than rendering a graph.
So what has happened here?
Why did we go from
60k flying to the moon
to four megabytes
rendering a graph?
And I think the reason
is that we fundamentally
changed how we do software.
So back then, when they did
the software for Apollo,
there was a dedicated team that
wrote this code line by line,
everything was on purpose,
everything was handcrafted,
so it was really meticulously
crafted to fit into this 60k,
and do exactly one
thing, fly to the moon.
Fast-forward to today.
How build I my app?
I use components.
I just went to the web,
downloaded some components,
stitched it all together.
Ta-da!
I have my app.
There's a great
advantage of this.
Right?
It took me only 30 minutes.
It was really easy.
I was super productive.
But there's also a
big, big drawback.
My application was really big.
So let's look into the details.
Which components
did I actually use?
For that, I brought you
my build.gradle file.
And this is essentially
the default file
that Android Studio
will generate for you.
And all I've done, I've
added two components.
I've highlighted them here,
so that it's easier for you
to see.
The first one is Guava.
Now, Guava, that's
Google's common components
for software
engineering and Java,
and they add a lot of
convenient classes.
And the thing I wanted
was immutable collections.
Because I thought my static
weather data, it's static,
so it should be an
immutable collection.
Right?
That's good software
engineering practice.
The other thing I
use is Android plot.
And that's just a library
I found in the internet.
There's probably lots more
of plotting libraries,
but I spotted this
one the first.
And AndroidPlot is really great.
It has lots of support for bar
graphs and all kinds of charts.
But I really needed
a line graph.
That's all I cared about.
So let's look what
this means for size.
How did these components impact
the size of my application?
And to get an idea, I
went to the APK Analyzer.
Now if you haven't seen this
tool before, it's really great.
It's part of Android Studio.
You will find documentation
on developers Android.com.
But what this does is it
gives you deep insight
into what contributes
to the size of the APK.
It can do resources and
all kinds of things,
but I'm only interested
here in the actual code.
So I've highlighted that at
the bottom there for you.
There is this com
Google package which
contributes 1.4 megabytes.
Well, that's Guava.
So I'm paying 1.4 megabytes
for a mutable collection.
This might be a very
extreme example,
but there's something that
is more realistic there as
well, which is AndroidPlot.
That's the second thing you see.
And that's 180K.
So my plotting library
takes 180K of APK size.
Now there will be
something in there
that I don't need, because
my actual application that's
the EU part down
there is only 35K.
That's the code I wrote.
You might think 35K for
a hundred lines of code?
That's a bit much.
Well, it is, because there's
all the auto-generated code,
most of which I
actually don't need.
So this brings us
to the question
how do I get from this, where
you can clearly see that Guava
and Android plot take
the majority of my APK
size, [INAUDIBLE] application
is really small, to something
that's more tailored,
that's more like the thing
that they did for Apollo.
Of course, we won't
get to something
as crafted as that without
doing all the investment,
but there must be some
kind of middle ground.
And that really is where a tool
like ProGuard and R8 comes in.
Because one of the
things it does,
it takes your application,
and it removes
all the unused components.
So the goal is to take
a componentalized build
that you've made into something
as tailored as possible,
and to remove all that code.
Now when I ask you, you all
said you already used this.
So you will know it's
really easy to enable,
because all you
have to do is you
have to head back to
your build.gradle file,
and then flip this one flag.
Right?
If Android studio
generated this for you,
then it will already
say minfyEnabled, false.
You just flip that to true, and
ta-da, you have a small app.
I see some people are shaking
their heads already here,
because, of course, that's
not really the truth.
So I did this for
my application.
I flipped the flag, and
there it was, more than 200
build time errors.
Hooray.
So I looked at these
errors, and I thought, OK,
what are they trying to tell me?
There's classes missing.
Classes I haven't even heard of.
What do I do?
How do I fix this?
Well, the first solution,
you search on the internet.
So I did.
And I found this great
piece of advice, which says,
just put dontwarn star into
your ProGuard configuration,
and everything will be fine.
Now, technically,
this is correct.
You put this in there,
and it will compile.
But there's a problem.
What this tells R8 is,
no matter what happens,
don't tell me about it.
And that means it will
mask these benign errors,
but it will also really mask
all the errors you actually
care about, where
something went wrong.
So how can we improve on this?
And to do that, we have to
actually deep dive a bit
into how R8 works.
Now I will talk about
R8 here, because that's
the tool I helped build.
But most of this also
applies to ProGuard,
because it solves
the same problem.
So what does R8 do?
It does two things.
Firstly, it does minification.
And minification is
the process, where
you take very long class
names and replace them
by very short class
names instead.
Some also call this
obfuscation, but it really
doesn't obfuscate your code.
It just makes it a
little less hard to read,
but it's nowhere safe
for reverse engineering.
So let's call this minification.
That's one thing ProGuard
does, but I don't
want to focus too much on that.
The other thing it
does is shrinking.
Now shrinking is a
great name for this,
from a developer perspective,
because it takes your app
and it shrinks it
into a smaller app.
If you actually
want to understand
what happens under the hood,
it works actually the other way
around.
Because what we're
doing is we're
doing tree growing,
which takes the entry
point of the
application and grows
that until we've
seen everything that
will be executed at runtime.
Let's look at the example here.
So I create these graphics.
And in essence,
a box is a class.
That's all you have
to care about for now.
There's also code
in these boxes,
but don't read it just yet.
Another thing on these graphs
is that everything on your right
is library classes.
That's part of the
Android system.
And everything on the left
is your application code.
And the first thing
to realize here
is that library classes
are always live.
And there's a very
practical reason for this,
because we can shrink
them away anyway.
They're on the phone.
They're part of the system.
But there's also a
technical reason,
because for a static
analysis tool,
we don't know what these
library classes actually do.
And that is because
the runtime might
call into them at any point.
There's very many
different libraries,
like different Android
versions, and they also
might change in the future.
So from an analysis
standpoint, we just
have to assume that the
library class is always live.
So let's assume we will start
our app by calling the run
method in the app class.
So the first thing we will
have to do to actually do this
is we have to instantiate
this app class, which
means we create an
instance of the class app,
and we also call
the constructor.
And that leads to both
of them being live.
That means we cannot
strip away the app class,
and we cannot strip
away the constructor.
So far, so good.
Next, we have to actually look
at the code of the constructor
to see what it
will do at runtime.
And if you look at
the code, you will
see it actually creates a
new instance of Class A.
So again, this makes
class A become alive.
We can no longer remove it.
Note that class doesn't
actually have a constructor.
So there is no code to look at.
It only has a default
constructor that
does nothing interesting here.
The other thing that the
constructor of the app class
does, it writes the
created instance
to this field, Other Field.
It's interesting to note
here that doesn't actually
make Other Field live.
Because writing to a
field is not observable.
You have to actually
read the field
to know that the field exists.
So now we've created the
instance of this app class.
We've executed the constructor.
We want to call the run method.
And again, calling
this run method
will mark this method as live.
And like with every
other live method,
we now have to look at it and
see what the code actually
does at runtime.
So if you look at
Run, you will see
it first reads the field Other
Field to retrieve the instance,
and this is the moment
where this field actually
becomes live.
And next, we will call A method
on the retrieved instance,
and that is where A method
in class A becomes live.
And now we would look
at the code of A method,
see what that does, and
mark all those effects.
So this is how the basic
analysis flow works.
Whenever you think
about keep rules,
you have to keep in mind, this
is what your analysis engine
will do.
Now, how does this
relate to Android?
How do we actually
know the entry point
of an Android application?
Well, that comes from
your manifest file.
So this is a very
simplified manifest file.
But one thing it
does, it tells you
that the activity has
the class, the graph,
as its implementation.
Now, neither R8 nor ProGuard
do understand manifest files.
And they shouldn't,
because there
is a little tool that actually
helps us understand them,
and that's called AAPT.
AAPT during a build process
pre-process all your resources,
and it creates corespondent
keep rules for you.
So let's look at this keep rule.
And this is the first keep rule.
So we'll talk a bit
about it in detail.
So what it basically
does, it says keep.
That's the simplest form.
It says, OK, everything I
mention now, you have to keep.
Don't touch it.
Don't shrink it.
Don't rename it.
And you want to keep
a class, and then we
have a fully
qualified class name,
which is my main class that
came from this manifest.
There's something more here.
Just the class name would
only keep the class.
It wouldn't actually
tell the system
that this class is
also instantiated,
which is a big difference.
To tell it about that, we also
have to keep the constructors,
and that's what
this init line does.
So this init, with the
elided parameters, tells R8,
we also need the constructors,
and we will instantiate this
at runtime.
So now, R8 knows
this class is live.
And as I said before, it
will look at the code.
Let's go there.
This is my TheGraph
class, and I've
removed all the function
bodies and everything
that's not important.
But what you will see
here is it actually
doesn't have a constructor.
So that means our
analysis ends right here.
We've seen the class.
There's no constructor.
Nothing to do.
Now, every one of you who's
ever written an Android app
knows the actual meat happens
in the onCreate method.
That's where the actual
configuration happens.
So how does R8 know?
The keep rule never told it
to actually look at onCreate.
Well, the trick here is
that the graph extends
this AppCompatActivity class.
And if you keep
on following this,
you will see that eventually
that extends activity.
Now activity is a Library class.
And as I said before,
all library classes
are always live.
Hence, this onCreate
method is also life.
But this is onCreate in
the library class is live,
all its overrides in live
subclasses also become live.
And that's another
thing of the analysis
you have to keep in mind
if you want to understand
how it actually works.
So this is what
marks onCreate life.
Let's take a look.
This is my onCreate method.
And it looks like a
standard onCreate method.
It first does some set up,
delegates to the superclass.
I want to highlight
only two things here.
The first is this findViewByID.
This calls the Library
method, and what it does,
it at runtime
dynamically returns
an object somewhere from your
view based on your layout.
Again, R8 cannot
really understand this.
Because this ID is, again,
defined in an XML file
somewhere.
This is my layout.
And you can see it
says this XYPlot
class is in my
constraint layout,
and it has this ID plot.
How do we figure this out in R8?
Again, AAPT comes to the rescue.
And this keep rule might
look quite similar,
but what it tells R8 that your
layout uses this XYPlot class,
and it will instantiate
it at runtime.
So it's always the
same principle.
Another thing I want
to highlight here
is that during this
addPlotSeries, where we set up
the plots, we use another
R identifier, which
is this R.xml.
Now, R.xml is different.
These are three XML
[INAUDIBLE] just
puts in your XML directory
in your resources.
There's no requirements
on their contents,
so AAPT cannot actually
understand them.
So when you use these
R.xml somewhere,
you are responsible for all the
keep rules that may require.
Just keep this in mind.
We'll come back to that later.
So this is the
basic analysis flow.
This is how this
basically works.
Now you might ask, OK,
200 error messages.
How does that relate?
What went wrong there?
I mean, this analysis
looks reasonable.
Why does it fail?
And the reasons is that
the analysis that we do
is different from
what the VM does.
And one difference
is annotations.
Now the Android
VM doesn't really
care about annotations at all.
They have no meaning at runtime
unless you use reflection.
So if an annotation
class is missing,
the Android VM will still
just execute that code
because it doesn't
even look at them.
In comparison, R8 has to
understand notation classes
because they might be
part of a keep rule.
So R8 has to find
these classes and has
to understand the hierarchy.
And if R8 can't, it
will warn you about it.
So that's a very common
source about these warnings,
is missing annotation classes.
The other thing is code
R8 just can't understand.
Here's an example,
which is class value.
So class value is a
concept from Java 7,
but that's not available
on the Android platform.
So this code will
actually fail at runtime.
When the entered VM
tries to execute it,
it will tell you this
clause is missing.
Why does this still work?
Because the creators of Guava
used this nifty trick here
to hide the missing class.
What they do is they load
the class via Reflection,
and if that fails,
they fall back
to some alternative
implementation.
Now, the Android VM will
understand this at runtime.
It will just throw an exception,
the exception gets caught,
and the alternative is executed.
But R8 cannot
understand this code.
It's just too complicated
to handle aesthetically.
And to fix these
errors, you just really
have to look at
all these examples
and find where they came from.
And ultimately, that
distills to these five
keep rules or warning
rules that you have to add.
Now the first three,
they just disable
warnings about certain
annotations from the checker
framework and error
prone, and those are just
static analysis tool frames that
are not used at runtime at all.
The bottom two are
two classes that
are not readily available
on the Android platform.
And they are typically used
via some reflective wrappers
to make this work at runtime.
So adding these five rules, we
get our application to compile.
That wasn't bad, right?
So we looked a bit at it.
We added five rules.
And ta-da, we have a
smaller application.
Unfortunately, the runtime
behavior of my application
has changed just
ever so slightly,
because now it crashes.
And that's the other
problem you typically see.
Again, what happened here?
Right?
I explained to you how
the analysis works.
That looked all
fine and reasonable.
The typical problem
is reflection.
Because by its mere
nature, reflection
is about using a
dynamic runtime value
to load a method or a clause.
And static analysis just
can't understand this.
Dynamic values are the
enemy of static analysis.
So how do we fix this?
Well, we have to
somehow figure out
how to tell our aide about
these cases of reflection
and make R8 understand them.
And that's really
what keep rules do.
So what did I do?
I went to the internet.
Unfortunately, the developers
of AndroidPlot put up
this rule on the internet,
which says, keep class--
OK, you want to keep some
classes-- com AndroidPlot,
star, star.
And what this means is it
tells R8 to essentially
not touch Android plot at all.
Again, this will
fix the problem.
It will run again, but
it will no longer shrink.
So this cannot be the
point in using R8.
So how can we improve on this?
And there's really
no clever way doing
this, other than going on
some forensics investigation.
We really have to find out
where all this reflection is
happening and what we have to
add toward the configuration
to make R8 understand it.
So where do you look?
Where do we find evidence?
And the first place
to look is adb log.
So I've preprocessed
this a bit here
so that it's easier to read.
But in essence, if you
go on Android Studio
and use the log viewer, you
can filter by Process ID,
and this is, in essence,
what you will see.
So there will be
this log statement
saying that styleable
definition not found for A.
As such, this is
not really helpful,
because I don't understand
what this is trying to tell me.
But it is really great,
because it gives me a place
to look in the source code.
So this is a big
piece of advice.
If you write these
kind of libraries
and you do a reflection,
put in logging statements.
It's not so important
that people actually
understand the message.
It's much more important
that people will find where
this statement was generated.
Because I have this
logging statement there,
I can now actually look at the
code and see what it's doing.
So here's plus plotjava.
And as you can
see down there, it
says log.d styleable
definition not found.
So what is going wrong here?
As you can see, this
does reflection.
There is this
styeableclass.getfield,
and styleable class
is a class object.
And get field will get
a field from that class,
give them the name,
styleable name.
So this is an example of
reflection on a class.
How is styleable name defined?
Because that's clearly
what is going wrong.
It's trying to find a
field called A. That
seems a strange field name.
This is how styleable name is.
I's defined by means
of getclass.getname.
So again, we have to
understand what this does.
What does getclass do?
That's, again, a
reflective invocation.
It will return what's called
in Java the current class.
Now if you're in this plot
file, and in the plot class,
the current class can be
the plot class itself,
but it can also be
any of its subclasses.
Because at runtime,
this method might
run in different
contexts, depending on how
the virtual dispatch worked.
And now we get the
name of this class,
and this seems to return A. Why
did they name their class A?
Well, they didn't.
The problem is minification.
Right?
R8 went ahead, saw this
class, and thought, well,
plot is a long name.
Let's call it A.
So to fix this, we
have to prevent R8 from
renaming this class or any
of its subclasses.
And this is the
corresponding keep rule.
So again, what does this say?
It says keep class
com androidplot.pot.
And that means R8
should keep the class,
not rename it, not optimize it.
But as I said, we also have
to keep all the subclasses,
so we have to say keep
class star extends
com androidplot.plot.
This will keep all subclasses of
plot and the plot class itself.
But is this actually
what we want?
If you think again about
what get class does,
it, at runtime, returns the
class of the current object.
Now, you can only
be the current class
if you have actually
been instantiated.
Right?
If a class never
gets created, there
is no way of getting
it via get class.
So our keep rules
do not actually
have to keep extra classes.
All we want is we
want to prevent them
from being renamed.
And that's where
modifiers come in.
So here's a modifier for you.
What this now does,
it still says keep.
But it says Allow Shrinking.
So it tells R8, if you
see this plot class,
you're allowed to remove
it if nobody uses it.
But if you keep it, don't rename
it, and don't optimize it.
And this will fix our
problem, because now the plot
class at runtime will
actually still be called plot,
as will be all the subclasses.
So that was not too bad, right?
You look a bit at the code.
You come up with two keep rules,
and your application will run.
Or not.
So it's still not working.
We have to do more
forensics work.
What do we do?
We go back to the adb log.
And the message has changed.
We now see a
different exception.
Again, it's not really clear
what this is trying to tell me,
but I have an exception
I can look for.
So this says, error
while parsing key,
linePaint.strokeWidth.
OK.
Why does this happen?
How do we find out?
We look at the code.
And here's the
corresponding method.
And I've highlighted the
reflective use in there
for you.
So again, you can
see, we take a class,
and they beget all its methods.
And next, we compare the name of
this method against some given
name we are looking for.
So there's two things
that can go wrong here.
We are just getting
a set of all methods
so we might have removed
too many methods.
And again, we're getting
the name of these methods,
so we might have renamed them.
So these are the
two error conditions
we now have to check.
What are we removing, and
what are we renaming that we
shouldn't?
Now I have to
admit, it's kind of
hard to figure out what this
code really does unless you
are the library developer.
So the person who wrote
this code initially
knows perfectly clearly
what this is doing.
And at that point, it
would have been really
easy to write these keep rules.
So what does this do?
Do you remember these?
So when we do this
addPlotSeries,
we configure what these series
are supposed to look like.
And AndroidPlot has this
really great feature
where you can tell it to
configure your graph based
on some XML file.
And this is what this
XML file looks like.
And as you can
see, in there, you
will find this
linePaint.StrokeWidth.
And what this library will do,
it will take this XML file,
it goes through all the
attributes in there,
and then it will call
corresponding getters
and setters on an object
it's trying to configure.
So we'll take a graph
object, and then we'll
call the get linePaint
getter, and then
set the StrokeWidth property.
This is a very standard pattern
of configuring something
at runtime, and it's a
really great feature.
But if R8 sees this, it
cannot understand this,
because R8 cannot make the
connection between this XML
file and the actual classes.
Also, as this is freeform XML,
we don't have AAPT to help us.
Instead, we have to
do this ourselves.
And this is the
corresponding keep rule.
What do we need to do?
We don't want to keep
[INAUDIBLE] extra classes,
because again, what
we're trying to do here
is we're trying to take an
object at runtime that already
exists, and then we
try to configure it
by calling getters and setters.
So that's why we use
keep class members.
That doesn't keep
any extra classes,
but it tells R8
if you're already
keeping a class in the
com AndroidPlot package,
also keep these members,
and don't rename them.
And what members
do we want to keep?
First of all, we
want to keep getters.
And what to getters look like?
They return some result--
that's the three stars.
They start with Get, and they
typically have no arguments.
So that first line in there
will keep your getters.
Similarly, we can keep setters.
So they don't return anything,
but they start with set,
and they take a single
argument of some type.
So this rule will now keep
the getters and setters,
so that runtime,
the configuaration,
can just happen.
So one more keep rule.
Do you think it will work now?
Let's take a look.
And yes, we made it.
So we added a couple
of keep rules.
And now, our application
is actually running again,
but was it worth it?
Because this was a bit
of an investment, right?
We had to look at the code.
We had to figure out
what it actually does.
Was this journey worthwhile?
Let's go back to
the APK analyzer.
And here, you can
see the results.
So if you look at com
Google, which is Guava,
that went from 1.3
megabytes to just 8K.
I know that's very
extreme, because I'm
using essentially a
couple of few classes
in this huge collection.
But also for AndroidPlot,
which is much more realistic,
you can see that it went
from 180K to about 100K,
and that's more than
one entire [INAUDIBLE]..
Also, if you look at
my app, you can see
that it went from 35K to 2K.
And 2K is a lot closer
to the 100 lines of code
I actually wrote,
because we removed
all the unneeded auto-generated
parts that the build
system has created for us.
Again, I've created
this graphic for you
to make this a bit more visual.
And as you can see,
Guava nearly disappeared.
AndroidPlot halved,
and my app also
turned into this
little sliver there.
So it was a bit of a journey,
but it really, really paid off.
So what's the
takeaway lessons here?
I hope I was able to
convince you that it actually
makes sense to look into size.
If you build an app, no matter
what your target audience
is, please invest into size.
Please invest into
creating keep rules.
Please use ProGuard or R8
to actually shrink your app.
But also, I hope I've
shown you some ideas of how
to make this easier.
And the first thing to
really take away here
is, you should consider
a size early on.
Because while you are
writing your code,
it is really, really easy to
also write your keep rules,
because you still understand
what that code is actually
doing.
Write all the code
examples we looked at,
if you had just
written them, it would
be easy to understand
why this goes wrong.
Also, you should add
structure to your code
to ease describing
reflective use.
You remember those getters
and setters example I had,
where I said, OK, all
classes and AndroidPlot,
keep the getters and setters?
These kind of things are
much simpler if you actually
have some kind of interface that
allows you to tighten these up.
So if you had an interface,
say, runtime configured object,
you could just say in a
keep rule, every object that
extends runtime configured,
keep these getters and setters.
And then it's independent
of the actual application,
then it can just be
part of that library.
And lastly, and
this sounds obvious,
but it's really important.
You should continuously
test and optimize build.
Again, the earlier you
find regressions in your
build, the easier
it is to fix them,
because you will still remember
what you actually changed,
and they will make it easy
to come up with keep rules.
If you are a library
developer, you
should really, really
carefully provide keep rules,
because there's
this multiplayer.
If you make precise keep rules,
all the users of your library
will benefit from it, and a lot
of apps will become smaller.
Don't make this an afterthought.
Invest into keep rules while
you build your library,
while you design your library.
Publish them
somewhere where people
can find them, because that's
typically what we all do.
We will search the
internet for rules to use,
so put them on your home page,
put them in the readme file,
make it visible.
And lastly, consider using
consumer ProGuard files
when you are shipping
via the AAR system,
because this makes it completely
transparent to your library
users.
When they enable ProGuard,
they will automatically
get your Keep Rules.
Lastly, please give us feedback.
So we've built R8,
we have tested it.
We believe it's a
drop-in replacement.
But only you can
actually find that out.
So if you're using ProGuard
today, give R8 a try,
tell us how it worked for you.
If you're not yet
using ProGuard,
try out R8, and see how far
you can get with shrinking,
and how good our diagnostics.
File bugs.
We have a really
responsive team,
and we really care
about your feedback.
And lastly, after this talk, you
can also see me at the sandbox,
or find me outside if
you want to have a chat.
And with that, I
want to thank you
very much for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]